Iran continuing to issue new threats
against Israel after the Gaza Hospital
blast the Iranian Embassy in Syria
tweeting that time is up in both Hebrew
and Arabic and a top Iranian Commander
threatened that Israel will face another
shock wave of attacks President Biden
could have said something about the
radical regime but he made no mention of
Iran during his speech today in Israel
how could he instead he issued this
vague threat a message to any state or
any other hostile actor thinking about
attacking Israel Remains the Same as was
a week ago don't don't
don't D referring to Alec Baldwin I mean
I maybe we'll find out one day why
they're so reluctant to actually say the
word you remember when there's six
billion re remember yeah exactly do you
remember during the Obama Administration
when they would never say radical
Islamic terrorism and then reporters
would ask them every day why won't you
call it that and they just refused to do
it and everybody knew what they were
talking about it's like we all know that
we're talking about Iran also do you
remember three weeks ago when the
traffic in New York was absolutely
terrible you know one of the reasons
because the UN General Assembly was here
and guess who else was here well we had
invited the Iranians to come and what
else did we do on that day we gave them
their the hostages back we did the trade
and the $6 billion was unfrozen and at
this point I'm thinking that they were
just probably laughing all the way to
the bank because they knew somebody
there had to have known that this was at
least going on or they're at least they
are funding it and we have been the mugs
for it plus they are this
to having a nuclear weapon and Israel is
not going to stand for that and neither
should we yeah judge it's like uh this
White House can't be trusted with Iran
given the fact didn't they have like a
mole in their in the white house or that
guy named Mali yeah something like that
yeah yeah I mean they have made so many
mistakes they've undone so many things
well you know you don't even have to dig
that deep Greg I mean look has anyone uh
pull back the six billion they're
watching it like Hawks though they're
watching it like a hawk look Iran
believes that we will continue to
appease Hamas and that's what Biden did
he went over there he said I got a
hundred million dollar for the
Palestinians and Israel make sure Hamas
gets it I mean make sure the Palestinian
gets it and Hamas doesn't interrupt okay
the bottom line is Iran saying time is
up or it's over is basically saying
we've got him cooking Hezbollah is
cooking we've got the the world
believing that you bombed a hospital
we've changed the narrative everybody
forgot you were cutting heads off a baby
and burning people alive and now we're
the winners so it's time to hit yeah in
The Green Room Harold you said hey Ran's
not so bad and then you walked away with
a brand new Persian
rug again I I don't remember all of that
they so I I would say this I have a
slightly different opinion if you know
that you are uh the person that
everybody wants to to name and they
don't name you if you think you're the
person everybody wants and I belittle it
so in such a small way you're the person
everyone wants to date and no one asks
you out the Iranians are having to
identify themselves as the culprit here
and you know what the leader of the Free
World went to Israel looked right at
them in the camera and then called their
names on and guess who felt little the
Iranians they had to they had to tweet
or whatever you call it exit to say
we're here time is up we know where you
are that's an and the president of the
United States told you on his most
recent trial
a way to look at it you know what the
White House is doing right now like dang
did you see what Harold said maybe we
should that should be our spin or our
president that's oh yeah Jesse um why
should we listen to Iran who I mean them
threatening Israel Israel is like so
what what can you do that hasn't already
been done to us well they do talk tough
but they can use proxies to harass them
and from the North and the South and
besides rugs they have pistachios one of
their best exports yes the
the oil sanctions Joe Biden took them
off because we needed oil prices
stabilized after the Ukraine war and
then the six billion the hostage swap we
have ships to go past them they never
ever respond to all the pot shots the
Iranians take and then we're paying
their proxies we're paying them
billions I and they're begging to get
back in the nuke deal so right now I
wouldn't do anything to the Iranians I
would just I would squeeze them I would
I would I would slap those uh missile uh
limit itations back on but if they
attack anywhere through Hezbollah or
through Hamas again you let the Israelis
take care of it you do not strike Iran
right now unless they kill Americans in
Iraq then you do something but I
wouldn't go a gungho into tyan they just
killed Americans Israel I I understand
I'm saying if if they launch missiles
from their soil into Israel or hits a
base with US soldiers in Iraq or S
anywhere then you go in but right now I
think you have him
contained you have Iran contained I
wouldn't strike Iran unilaterally right
now at all I think that's a very bad
idea all right I agree with you there
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else